hello everyone I'm Lisa Booth along with
Jason schaetz Tommy lren and Joe kcha
and welcome to the big weekend show the
big story
tonight articles of impeachment revealed
against Homeland Security secretary
Alejandro
mayoras the border is closed the border
is secure it is my testimony that the
border is secure but you do think it's a
crisis
now Brett it is a
challenge well that in assistance is
just one reason the house argues mycus
is putting her National Security at risk
Fox News correspondent Lucas tomson is
live to break down the details of the
two articles of impeachment
Lucas well Lisa Republican member of the
House Homeland Security committee spoke
on Fox and Friends earlier about those
impeachment articles and that testimony
you heard earlier from the DHS Chief the
articles are very simple article one
says that there's a willful and systemic
refusal to follow the law that's the
immigration and National nationality act
in article two says that there's a
breach of public trust what you just
heard those two are very simple but they
factually outline the refusal of
secretary my orcus to keep our country
sa
safe now here's the text Lisa Alejandro
n maoris knowingly made false statements
to Congress that the border is secure
that the border is quote no less secure
than it was previously and that the
border is quote closed and that DHS has
quote operational control of the border
the text continues throughout his tenure
as Secretary of Homeland Security
Alejandro n my orcus has repeatedly
violated laws enacted by Congress
regarding immigration and border
security in large part because of his
unlawful conduct millions of aliens have
illegally entered the United States on
an annual basis with many unlawfully
remaining in the United States his
refusal to obey the law is not only an
offense against the separation of powers
in the Constitution of the United States
it also threatens our national security
now here's the response from DHS to all
this says quote this farce of an
impeachment is a distraction from other
vital National Security priorities and
the work Congress should be doing to
actually fix our broken immigration laws
now many republican congressmen say the
southern border is should be the top
National Security priority here's house
Foreign Affairs committee chairman Mike
McCall earlier on Fox News Sunday he
knows better this is not by accident
it's by Design and he I call him the
architect of Destruction U 8 million
encounters uh 300 on the terror watch
list 200 million people dead now thanks
to fentel poisoning that this one man is
responsible for I think that is a
dereliction of
Duty now Lisa cabinet members only been
impeached one time in the history of the
United States and that happened nearly
150 years ago Lisa we'll see if it
happens again Lucas thank
you all right Jason so two articles
we've got here refusal to follow the law
breach of public trust are these
articles of impeachment Justified and
then what's the process of this what are
the next steps I I've read through the
20 pages of the Articles of impeachment
they are Justified the secretary has not
enforced the current law he's made
excuses he's made representations to
Congress that are false that are
absolute total lies you can look at all
the numbers and probably one of the best
witnesses that you'll have will be
somebody like a Brandon Jud who's in
charge of the border patrol Union talk
to the border patrol agents they're not
allowed to enforce the current law yeah
there were a lot of other things like
the whipping incident with the horses
that was totally false but what about
the tens of thousands of unaccompanied
miners that were released into the
country he made representations about
that that's also in the Articles talking
about how that is a dereliction of
Duties so he's lost the public trust
Congress the United States Senate has a
co-equal vote in how they approve that
person to be in that role and as Edwin
me has written in the past they Congress
the Senate has a co-equal uh voice to
get rid of that person and I think he's
earned this unfortunately it's not going
to change unless they get rid of that
person who is not enforcing the current
law well they'll have tough time in the
the Senate as well obviously all right
you know Tommy let's listen to
congresswoman Lee stefanic a house
Republican conference
chair we are holding the Biden
Administration in Jo Biden accountable
for the catastrophe at our Southern
border has been a willful and refusal to
comply with the law and an abusive power
in the position as Secretary of Homeland
Security every state is a border state
so the committee will mark up those
articles of impeachment and work through
the process to bring them to the floor
and I think what's most telling is
Democrats are refusing to hold Joe Biden
accountable for this border crisis that
Joe Biden and his cabinet have
created so you heard it right there
Democrats refusing to hold Joe Biden
accountable how's that going to play out
politically let's be fair also some
Republicans that are refusing to hold
Joe Biden accountable it feels like
we're listening to this on a loop for
the last three years Republicans saying
that the border is a problem the Border
needs to be closed the laws need to be
enforced everybody is you know giving us
a dereliction of Duty we hear this over
and over and over again like a broken
record and I'd love to hear Republicans
say it but it took this long first of
all for this impeachment to the inquiry
to even come up when it when it comes to
mayorcas that's been promised for many
many months now but I think the American
people are also sick of Republicans and
Congress talking about this it doesn't
seem like they actually have the will or
the votes or the support within
themselves to get it done and then you
look at Texas which is actually out
there making a change making a
difference holding the line so I think
more Americans are looking at Governor
Greg Abbott and saying we need maybe 50
more Greg Abbotts out there and then we
could get something done but I'm not
going to hold my breath it's great that
we have this it's nice to see some
movement is it going to go across the
Finish Line I'm sorry I don't have a lot
of optimism there a lot of Americans
don't well you know Joe Tommy was
talking about how Republicans are even
at odds on this issue as well I want to
play this clip of of just that you know
I want to play this clip of Senator Rick
Scott as well as Langford who are on
opposite sides of this let's take a
listen this bill focuses on getting us
to zero illegal Crossings a day there's
no amnesty this is not about letting
5,000 people in a day this is the most
misunderstood section of this proposal
we could change all these laws
there's laws now Trump secured the
Border Biden decided to open the border
under the exact same laws we don't need
a new bill we need something to enforce
to force Biden to comply with the law so
you've got Republicans at odds with each
other in the backdrop of this
impeachment uh as well and then you've
got the media coming to the defense of
Democrats on top of it the Washington
Post said this it says House GOP unveils
myc's impeachment articles despite lack
of evidence despite 20 pages of it laid
out from Republicans
crisis seriously wow I think you'll see
the Cowboys in the Super Bowl before you
see the media actually report on this
honestly right 10,000 people a day in
December crossed into this country
illegally 300,000 in a month all right
so what more evidence do you need that
when myarc says the border is closed and
then 300,000 people are coming in in a
month more than 9 million since this
president took office it's not going to
be reported on honestly and then even if
we go from 10,000 a day to 5,000 a day
you know what Biden and the media are
going to do we have cut down border
crossings by more than 50% just like
they did with inflation Alejandra
mayorcas is a useful or useless idiot
you could remove him it doesn't matter
because another my orcus will just be
put in there as long as Joe Biden is
President and as long as wall
construction is not restarted and remain
in Mexico is not reinstated and catch a
release is is not eliminated this
problem will continue forever my
question for Jason real quick if you
don't mind do they have the numbers to
remove my orcus or is it just
impeachment and then oh well we couldn't
actually get him out of there well I am
worried talking to my house former house
colleagues that they don't the
Republicans don't you know they can only
give up three votes or so they don't
necessarily have the numbers to actually
impeach him should they go through this
process yes because the law says if
somebody comes in between the the ports
of
they shall be detained and shall be
deported but that's the The Catch and
Release that's going on now is a
violation of that law and it's being
done in mass and again I go back to the
the impeachment says I think 45,000
unaccompanied minors but I heard other
numbers as high as 85,000 imagine that
these are these are kids six 7 8 10
years old that are released and they
don't know where they are and there's
why is there no outrage if Donald Trump
released three people in into this
country that we unaccompanied miners
there's Stu if you go to the homeland
security website right now go type in
you know Homeland Security and go to
their website they talk about it's it's
human trafficking Awareness Month
they're the most complient people in
human trafficking that there is right
now because they are literally taking
the work of the cartels and getting
these poor young women and boys to who
knows what and if you talk to the border
patrol the thousands of people that are
raped coming across that border
Alejandro mayaras is in charge of it and
he's not doing his job and he needs to
be removed he's not doing his job and
then you have a Republicans in the
Senate trying like lenford which we just
heard from trying to codify 5,000
illegal immigrants per day which goes to
show what hope is there if this even
passes the house the impeachment and
gets to the Senate we have an election
coming up though so Republicans who were
unhappy with the representation
immigration should be the number one
issue remember that we have the power
well polling is showing that it's
becoming that hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else